hello everyone and uh for those of you
who are wondering why the hello everyone
sounds a bit
different now uh it's uh probably due to
anesthesia i still haven't uh
gotten to the to the absolute top of my
pitch for my voice uh so it will
probably take some time
uh but i am you know trying trying the
uh
as best as i can so don't worry it it'll
get to your
uh to the pitch that you are used to
now getting back to this game it's from
round eight of the ultibox norway
championship
a clash of the nords magnus carlson
versus ariantari
it's quite the game sure you're gonna
enjoy it uh so let's
dive straight into it magnus has the
white pieces and he opens
with e4 and i wanted to show you
something just uh give me a second
uh i did prepare it uh there we go yeah
there it is
uh we do have a nice photo of this event
as this is not an online event
this is an actual over the board event
so here's a very nice photo by leonard
otis uh let's just uh make that a little
bit smaller
uh well that's pretty big uh let's
make that yeah even more smaller uh
there we go
so there you have it a very nice photo
by leonard otis there you have it magnus
carlsen and ariana tari
uh and as you can see uh taree removed
his wrist watch from his hand which
seems a bit weird
uh why would you bring your wrist watch
you know to a chess game you're gonna be
sitting there for like six hours but
uh if you've ever brought a wristwatch
to a chess game you you understand this
move and
and you know what i'm talking about so
uh getting back to the game
magnus opens with e4 and we have e5
knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to
b5
the rule lopez is on the board and i
just wanted to say
also regarding this tournament i don't
know if i've mentioned it
this is a classical tournament but every
game
every classical game that ends in a draw
uh there is immediately an armageddon
game played and
the the the encounter cannot end in a
tie so
you will not get the full three points
you will get uh two points for winning
armageddon whereas your opponent only
gets one
but you know yeah if you draw the
classical game it's not it's not a tie
so that's
uh i i like this tournament uh and okay
we have a6 morphe's defense with bishop
to a4 and now
knight to f6 we have castles by magnus
and bishop to e7 so this is the absolute
main
uh main theory stuff we have d3 and b5
challenging the bishop bishop back to b3
and now
d6 and now as the flank here has been
extended magnus attacks at with a4
uh we have bishop to d7 now if white
wants to trade then the rook is also
nicely defended so not a problem
uh we have c3 by magnus uh in the future
you will have support for
for d4 and now knight to a5 this is all
very standard
you move the knight you want to make
room for your c pawn also you challenge
the bishop here
and the white will usually go bishop to
a2 or bishop to c2 bishop to c2 is a
much more frequent move here
however magnus decides to test
the the young tardis now knowledge and
goes bishop to a2 instead
uh and okay he continues pushing we have
c5 and bishop to g5 now
continuing development nothing out of
the ordinary happening here
uh we have castles by tari uh and here
there are a couple of moves that
were tried in this position a captures
on b5 is a known move
also developing the knight via the a3
square is a known move putting pressure
on the b5 pawn
uh however magnus goes for knight beat
to d2 and it is now as of move 12
do we have a completely new game and
toddy has uh well
has his hands full so to say he
continues with
rook to b8 puts um pressure along the b
file there's the immediate uh well
threat of just capturing
the pawn and then capturing the b pawn
so magnus captures uh on b5 by himself
we have captures captures and
now rook to e1 uh can just continuing
development of his pieces we have b4
thought he has a rook on the b file so
we might as well open up the b
file and knight to c4 by playing by
playing b4 you've
allowed the whites to gain access to the
c4 square
with his knight and this is exactly what
magnus does
uh and toddy very happy to uh to trade
off
a pair of knights as his knight is not
doing all that much on the edge of the
board
so we have captures here captures and
another character
captures captures and the queen to c7
continuing development
uh or rather finishing development now
the rooks are connected and you just
want to get this rook into the game
probably with something like rook b7
rook to b8
and magnus does the same queen the c2
the rooks are now connected
they've become rows for life and magnets
is also now ready
uh well figure out a game plan so to say
and here uh with bishop to b5 by tari
he wants to trade off uh as many pieces
as possible but there were other moves
to consider
uh you could challenge white's bishop
with h6 you could just continue with
your developing plan bishop rook to b7
followed by rook to b8 you could just uh
play bishop to c6 just getting the
bishop to uh
to a more useful uh diagonal uh however
bishop to b5 i guess was inspired by the
fact that
okay i'm playing magnus of course i want
to trade down as much as possible and
try and grab half a point in in the
classical game
and okay bishop to b5 magnus decides to
capture we have
bishop captures rook captures and now
bishop captures on f6
and here is an important moment to
realize that yes
now you do want to capture bishop for
knight because after characters and
captures
what do you realize well you realize
that black has a backward spawn on d6
white also has a backwards pawn on d3
but it's much harder for black to reach
white's backwards pawn
and this knight this knight is
definitely going places this knight is
coming to d2
the uh the c4 he's coming to e3 and then
he's coming to d5 and on d5
this knight will be a monster as the
title of the video suggests on the other
hand
toddy has a dark square bishop and all
of his pawns are on dark squares he's
going to have
uh he's going to have some trouble
maneuvering his bishop around so here at
knight to d2 magnus immediately goes
towards the plan of shifting the knight
to the central d5 square
queen to c6 tari now hopes to play d5 he
wants to get rid of that backward spawn
but magnus doesn't allow it with a trick
queen to a4 now of course d5 just runs
into captures captures you
the rook will be unguarded so rook f the
b8 now the rook
is guarded and knight to c4 again magnus
tries to get tidy to push d5
but it's actually a trick because you
just lose the pawn if the e5 knight a3
the rook is under attack and if you
don't want to uh well
lose everything you have to trade queens
with rook to b6 and then
magnus just picks up a pawn and you
don't really have a good way of dealing
with this because the pawn can easily be
protected
and even after rook to b3 like going
after the pawn here you could go knight
b5 you attack
the rook once the rook moves you play
rook a3 the pawn is defended and you
just enjoy
a beautiful end game where you already
have a past d5 pawn
so after this knight to c4 move we first
have bishop to e7 by tari he wants to
shift the bishop over to f8 keep the
keep everything intact and now comes g3
magnus wants to play king to g2
improve the position a little and then
decide where to go from then
we have queen to c8 and now uh you could
have some ideas of maybe infiltrating
with the queen but also just you can
move the rook now because the queen is
not hanging on c6
so here queen back to d1 now magnus also
realizes that the queen is no longer
needed there he's going to bring the
queen over to f3
and hopefully infiltrate with rook to a7
so here tari continues with the g6 and
king the g2 with bishop to f8 uh now the
bishop
will be very useful there uh however you
still have to be
careful of this knight if this knight
comes to e3 and then here and then
he can check you from here if you bring
the bishop to g7 uh then the knight can
check you here so it's going to be
uh it's going to be a nightmare
defending
against this monster guy here so queen
to f3
and now rook to b3 finally you get this
very nice rook lift
and the c3 pawn is unprotected now while
you could go for the active rook to a7
immediately threatened queen captures on
f7
and decide what happens after rook to b7
uh
magnus just calmly decides to defend the
c1 pawn and we're gonna take it from
there
we can always uh first re-maneuver the
knight over here that's probably what
we're gonna do
uh before any uh active rook lifts uh
however we have queen to e6 by tari
uh and now magnus says okay now it's a
reason as a reasonable time as any to
make
this work lift so rook to a7 and now
rook 8 to b7 of course uh offering a
rook trait here
magnus trace here very important
captures captures
and now rook to a1 now the other rook
can come to a8 and pose
more problems for the black king and
here
uh while you could go for for something
like rook to b8
uh try and prevent that then you just
allow white to go for rook to a7 so a
real cliff is happening whether you like
it or not
so tari instead goes h5
uh he starts expanding on the king side
and magnus says okay
rook to a8 we have king to g7 unpinning
now the bishop can move and now knight
to a3
now the knight is coming to d5 and the
position is incredibly complicated like
if you think that black can just
waste moves and wait for you know white
to figure something out
uh you would be more than mistaken for
example if you try something like bishop
to e7 to repeat moves like this
you immediately run into knight f5 check
it it's incredibly ugly
and uh well although you don't have to
capture it you can move the king and
then you run into rook to e8 and it's
just an incredibly ugly position if you
capture it you just get the immediate
queen h5
check uh this is now the threat of
checkmate and if you defend with queen
to h6 then just check and you lose the
queen and of course you're going to lose
the game so it's not
a a position where you can just waste
moves so
toddy finds one such move where you can
waste the move queen to d7 is one option
he decides to go for rook to c7
as he wants to actively ask magnus to
trade off a pair of rooks
so magnus continues with knights to d5
his knight finally lands on the
beautiful d5 square and rook to c8
offering a trade but magnus just
declines rook to a7
we have rooked a b8 and now h3
now magnus says okay g4 is coming and
we're opening up the king side whether
you like it or not
we have rook to d8 again toddy wants to
play rook to d7 12 for a rook trade and
g4 by magnus we have captures captures
and now
rook to d7 a trade is offered but
the problem is uh rook to a8 and there's
not
uh there's not all that much uh you can
do here you could you could try a lot of
things but like
g5 is coming then it's gonna be it's
going to be very
problematic for you to do anything from
there so instead we have rook to d7
rook to a8 and now f6 like
inviting g5 but with a prepared f5 and
this is exactly what magnus does
magnus says okay g5 we now have a triple
attack here on the
on on the f6 square and uh well you
could uh like
place a rook on f7 just knight captures
on f6 it's
not not an issue for white so instead f5
is played
and now comes queen to h3 going after
that
queen to h6 move uh and here uh tari uh
defends with rook to f7 and here we
reach a beautiful position
uh where magnus played a beautiful
tactical shot so feel free to pause the
video
and try to find the winning idea there
are many winning ideas but the absolute
strongest winning idea for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
uh you know the the absolute monster of
a move in the position
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's rook to e8
and rook to e8 with the sole purpose of
removing the queen from the defense of
the g6 pawn
and while you don't have to capture the
rook it doesn't really help
uh help if you don't capture it for
example if you play queen to d7
uh move that just gets the queen out of
the way just queen h6
check king to g8 and now you again get
to capture the g6 pawn
uh you could you cannot block with the
bishop because uh well the bishop is pin
so you have to move the king but now
knight to f6 threatening checkmate
also the queen is under attack uh you
still cannot move
anything and there's just not nothing
you can do here for example if you
capture on f6
you're just gonna get queen captures
king to h7 and now let's say g6
check king h6 rook captures or queen
captures doesn't really matter
checkmate is coming so here after this
uh rook to e8 idea tari said okay i mean
i might as well capture it
because well we've just seen what
happens if i don't
so here queen the h6 by magnus king the
g8 and the now
queen captures on g6 and now of course
blocking with the rook just runs into
queen captures queen
so you can't do that so king to h8 was
played
and here magnus played knight to f6 and
it was
in this position that arientari resigned
the game
and a full three points for a win in the
classical time form
for magnus carlsen in round eight of the
ultibox norway championship
so here you resign because a mate is
being threatened also your queen is
hanging and you don't have a way of uh
defending here like if you capture the
knight
then just queen captures queen and you
don't even keep a bishop and rook
against the queen because
now the rook is hanging and if you move
the rook anywhere well you're just
losing the bishop
and other than that you don't really
have a good reply here if you block with
bishop to g7
so now this mate is not possible uh this
mate becomes possible because now
the rook has no control of the h7 square
so yeah after knight to f6 tari resigned
the game and
what a brilliant attacking game by
magnus carlsen really not
much happened there uh it was simply a
matter of
exploiting a better position to the
maximum
magnets having a beautiful monster
knight and the five tari having a dark
square bishop and his
pawns were also on dark squares so it
was incredibly hard
for him to to even make moves at this
game uh but yeah uh quite a game uh here
for those of you who
still uh haven't seen the standings or
for some reason don't remember the
standings
uh here they are magnus in first place
with 16 and a half points followed by
alireza ferrugia
and here we're going to have an
incredible clash in round nine because
we have carlson versus ferugia
and uh carlson won their previous uh
previous game
uh in uh in the first part of the
tournament now alex has a chance to
the strike back uh we'll see what
happens as the the battle for the future
continues
then we have 11 aaron in third place
fabiano carwana in fourth young shisht
of dudain in fifth and
arientari still on point and a half uh
in sixth place
but you know it's not easy rolling it
out with these monsters here
uh uh that's uh that's the game uh i do
hope you enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank
milan simon johansson srivastava
uh raymond young and the dustin jonatha
for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
uh continuing uh of course this very
short coverage of the
ultimate snowy championship checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day next
game is
firuja vs carlson uh see you soon